in our series a more perfect union name
to show that what unites us as Americans
is far greater than what divides us and
this week we go to Detroit to see a
program that's helping high school
students get into college it's called
midnight golf and a CBS News special
correspondent James Brown shows us it's
been an amazing success you may have
heard of midnight basketball which is a
nationwide effort to get kids off the
street out of trouble and into the gym
instead but midnight golf is an
after-school program it teaches kids how
to play golf and to win in the game of
life and we saw the program in action
and met the passionate woman behind it
all it's a cold January night in Detroit
but Rene Fluker has all the warmth these
high school students could possibly need
things my kids I love every one of them
I hug him when they come in I hug them
when they leave these kids are part of
midnight golf a four day a week after
school program that aims to give high
school seniors into college while
teaching them the game of golf
then they golf started 18 and a half
years ago was it a dream of yours it was
not a dream of mine
I was a single parent and raising a
young man trying to put him in every
type of sports it is and we found our
passion which was called the inspiration
for midnight golf came from Rene fluke
her son Jason
he learned golf in middle school and
went on to play in high school in
college he made the suggestion to his
mom he came up to me and said mom you
got to go back and show the kids in
Detroit the game of golf I see you
should think about it look what it did
for me and kept me on the straight and
narrow she took it to heart miss Fluker
put her talents as a state social worker
to use for my babies she borrowed $1,000
from her 401k gathered support from
local businesses and then she paid a
visit to the Michigan Professional
Golfers Association I'm like well I want
to start this program in Detroit and I
need your help I need your prose and I
need some money and then I said I looked
around his office I'm like we don't even
have Tiger Woods
I could tell she was sincere and genuine
but very forward and I respected that
Kevin helm is the executive director of
the Michigan section of the PGA of
America why involve yourselves with
midnight golf this is a way that we
could try to diversify the game and get
involved to help young people in Detroit
Michigan PGA became a partner from the
very beginning and provides eight
volunteer professionals every week to
teach the kids what were you hoping to
accomplish with it my goal was to always
get kids in college the program started
in 2001 with just 17 kids today it's a
free 30 week program for 265 high school
seniors with a 2.3 million dollar budget
the kids get dinner golf instruction
small group mentorship from local
leaders and cottage counseling that
culminates with a college tour in the
spring I got accepted into Penn State
and North Carolina A&T what's been the
success of sending students to college
ninety-eight percent that's higher than
the national average significantly yes
what are you guys doing giving them love
we want them to be successful dr. amber
Glenn is an example of that success she
went through the midnight golf program
in 2006 and it changed her life for me
being a participant in the midnight golf
program was an eye-opener in itself
right midnight golf said these are all
of the possibilities of things that you
could be she played golf in college and
then went on to medical school here you
can see the heart beating right here and
dr. Glenn credits miss Renee she is a
motherly figure to me she has been
personally vested in my success circle
just raised Jason Malone is now 37 and
serves on the board of midnight golf
with his mom he's overwhelmed by what
she's accomplished Detroit is a really
tough place to exist the goal of this
program was just to give him a chance it
really means a lot to to give back and
that all started with my mom
we cannot lose hope on our kids somebody
just got to believe in what they doing
if you believe they know they'd do it
since Rene Fluker started midnight golf
back in 2001 the program with support
from the PGA of America and numerous
volunteers has helped over 2,500 Detroit
students graduate high school go on to
college and some earn scholarships it
truly is a labor of ongoing love boy he
has a lot of love also known as Miss
reneik it's so true one person can make
a difference when kids think that you
care something is simple simple as a hug
or a love or a smile what a giant
accomplishment not a small difference
out there there's no that's that
changing kids lives literally I love her
son too
who's there so proud of his mom nicely
done very nicely done